welcome back it's time for graves
hypocrite of the week yes this is a new
segment where I single out a person who
says one thing and then does another
this week's hypocrites hypocrite
is Greg Gutfeld why because on this show
I've slammed the use of secret
recordings and gotcha videos where
undercover investigators get lowly
staffers to narc on their bosses while
at bars frankly if you record people
long enough while they're drinking you
can get him to say anything and that
scares me except when it comes to see it
end Project Veritas released recordings
of CNN's news call between staffers in
Jeff Zucker where he validates all your
assumptions about the chief goal of his
biased network to be the Trump
impeachment network in order to get
eyeballs and revenge while still calling
it news channe ring now do I feel good
discussing this sneaky stuff no but I do
feel good that we're hearing from the
horse's mouth exactly what we knew all
along that after doing their best to
make Trump the nominee figuring he'd
lose CNN must now destroy Trump because
he won it's not news to you we all knew
this but now it can be no longer denied
by CNN which is nice
given all the times they've accused
Trump supporters of being dumb sheep
like this crap fest from last night if
enough Americans because remember Trump
has 30 31% of hardcore they'll follow
him to hell or wherever he's going they
don't care about the facts they don't
know about the facts okay they're fine
people except they're ignorant about
these things that we're talking about
and they will not budge from that
so does that snap on and snap off
so was that commentary or news who cares
it's all the same to them and it's made
to order for their boss so as much as I
hate secret recordings I will take this
one and by the way so should CNN I mean
they do love a good whistleblower don't
they all right Jesse yes how do you feel
about this okay with Donaldson's hair
yes I love it yeah I do wish I had hair
like that you will one of these days I
just have to comb it over a little bit
more to the front and then wow that's a
helmet and it looks good on him but I
don't believe anything else he says what
is the plus or minus on the on this
leaky video well I'm not great by the
way okay I'm not blown away by the
content of it I think that the president
of CNN saying that we got to follow
impeachment we had to follow impeachment
heart is not breaking news yeah or that
he said let's call out Lindsey Graham
okay or he said Fox News is destructive
he said that out in the open many many
times the people that they did get
access to seemed to me to be kind of
low-level players without any editorial
power and they said things as you
mentioned that that sucker feels guilty
about The Apprentice and now it's trying
to get revenge or that people in the
elevator on election night were pretty
bummed out at CNN yeah
that's not breaking news to me the main
takeaway is is that CNN says it's a
non-biased down the middle straight news
organization even in primetime when
they're clearly not but other than that
I think the guy's kind of a rat more of
a disgruntled employees not a
whistleblower cuz nothing out there on
the tape was illegal and I think he'll
never get hired ever ever again this is
the I think one or two videos have come
out we're expecting a third I'm
anticipating something more I'm excited
I think O'Keefe is a great journalist
and a brave guy is looking for truth but
at this point I'm still waiting for
bigger more explosive things Danny that
was very fair and balanced from Jesse he
said he liked the work but was
disappointed in the product wait for the
next can't wait for the next one but I
think what gets me is you brian Stelter
is actually writing a book about fox
news he works at CNN he's writing a book
they're constantly calling a state run
and
and talk about without Fox News exactly
I'm not just saying it but so now we
know that actually they're kind of run
with an ideology here's the thing I
don't like secret videos I know I think
people I apologize for that that was
terrible I think that when if you are
competing against one another in terms
of ideology or a corporation or a team
or something like that win on the merits
like for example if you if this was a if
there was a sports oriented James
O'Keefe and he went into the team
meeting in the locker room the cowboys
and it gave the information to the Eagle
[Laughter]
Philadelphia then I think that feels
like oh look that's what they were gonna
do and I think people would be outraged
by that if the cowboys and the Eagles
can fight it out and see who wins yeah
and it'll probably be one can I can i I
I'm gonna float a theory yeah okay
during the election FNC wasn't Trump TV
we had like nineteen candidates we were
having all these intense fights you know
I you know I wasn't for Trump I was like
I was a Rubio guy we were all like but
we were all fighting about it but CNN
none of those other candidates mattered
one the Republican side they put all
their eggs on Trump and I think now
they're they feel guilty about that so
calling a state runs hilarious but they
were they were actually this is their
penance well I know I said if you're
right about the supper Trump
relationship which I think has been
written about extensively and CNN did
give a lot of airtime but I think we all
gave a lot of airtime to Donald Trump I
think we were we were the fairest
network of all because we the fight we
were practically ripping each other's
throats
yeah no no but I'm what I'm saying yes
forget what we say it was the coverage
of the Trump rallies which I mean I
didn't think trumpeted all that well in
the debates I mean the bullying language
like but the rallies is what was great
TV and everybody just covered it as TV
without understanding
hey this has political consequence but
to my mind I've been you know I've
worked for several journalistic
organizations and so if you wiretap to
any of our morning editorial calls I
think you would hear stuff then you
would say that a bias is that a night
advice look there's no bias in the boss
saying to you impeachment and Trump are
the biggest story in American politics
right now so I'm with Jesse on this I
don't see that there's anything newsy or
even evidence of bias and saying hey you
reporters don't lose sight of the big
story because that's what our audience
wants to hear about now Emily I would
say that they make it the big story by
saying that it's like we have to keep
this thing going we have to keep the
flame going yeah they're creating their
own fire what struck me about the what
came out on those tapes were when the
guy said that they meaning the CNN
executives that they don't like Tulsi
Gabbard because she takes an
unconventional route with policy and
that just that is exactly what comes out
of the left and the Democrats is they
will never support free-thinking and
that was the saddest part to all is not
that they're focusing on Trump and
impeachment but that they are ignoring
everyone else that deserves attention
final point yes kills me maybe because I
travel so much that 323 million people
are subjected to CNN in the airports and
I encourage every airport to let their
contract lapse just like SFO just did
because people are getting tired of it
and now that it's so clear you can't buy
bottled water or watch CNN so they're
not renewing their contract their
argument was that so many people have
their smart phones who are they gonna
sign zeros well we can put in a pitch we
should maybe we should there you go they
love us in San Francisco